وقد دعا نائب قائد القوات الروسيه في
اوكرانيا
في كلمه مسجله قوات وقيادات فاجنر للتوقف
والعوده لقواعدها وقال
ان كيف تنتظر اي زعزعه في سياسه الداخليه
الروسيه مشددا على انه لا يجوز اللعب
لصالح العدو على حد تعبيره
بامر من وزاره الدفاع الروسيه حضرت من
الجبهات الاماميه حيث ينفذ جنودنا
وقيادتنا ومتطوعون المهام ويقاتلون حتى
الموت رغم قوه العدو الكبيره يتكبدون
الخسائر ولكنهم صامدون في مواقعهم ادعوا
قياداتي ومقاتلي شركه فاجنر للتوقف العدو
ينتظر اي توتر في الوضع السياسي الداخلي
لا يجوز اللعب لصالح العدو في هذه الاوقات
الصعبه على البلاد قبل ان يفوت الاوان من
الضروري الالتزام باوامر الرئيس الروسي
الذي اختاره الشعب بالوسائل السلميه فقط
تعالج المسائل بقياده القائد العام للقوات
الروسيه
وصف قائد اداره العمليات في هيئه الاركان
الروسيه فلاديمير
ان ما يحاول يحاول فعله ملك شركه فادي
وقادته هو بتنفيذه اذا في هذا الامور
يعتبر
كانه يعتبر بحق القياده العسكريه الروسيه
بما يوصف بالجنون وشدد ايضا على ان ما
يحدث يعد ضربه في ظهر البلاد ورئيسها في
ظل الوضع الصعب الذي تمر به روسيا على حد
تعبيره
احتراما كبيرا للعديد من مقاتلي وقاده
شركه فاجنر العسكريه الخاصه الذين ينفذون
مهام جاده لصالح بلادنا لكن ما يحدث الان
هو امر صارخ لا يمكنني ان اصفه بكلمه اخرى
سوى الجنون تمر بلادنا الان بوضع صعب
اجتمع العالم الغربي فيه ضدنا ويتم توريد
الاسلحه والذكائر من كل ارجاء العالم وهذه
الاشياء التي تحاولون تنفيذها تحت افكار
استفزازيه ستؤدي الى خسائر كبيره وبالدرجه
الاولى لخسائر سياسيه تخيلوا كيف يستقبل
الغرب بحماسه ما تحاولون فعله الان بغض
النظر عن نياتكم النبيله فان ذلك يشكل
ضربه في ظهر البلاد والرئيس